you got any real you know horrific
dating stories from your own life that
we could exploit it's just 20 minutes
ago no I had a right to be in your room
[Laughter]
I did the best I could
what are lot of stress well I hope you
feel like you know me better
III you know I'm married now so I don't
have I mean I guess I am fun dating I
would get to be keep it alive in our
house but you know we have romantic
times but I when I was single or I would
I remember one time I was trying to get
out of a relationship that was very
toxic and very bad and really a downer
and I could never do it because I never
wanted to be the you know the person who
does the thing that hurts the other
person and I has having coffee with a
friend of mine and afterwards I looked
at my phone and there was a message from
the guy that I wanted to not be in a
relationship with anymore turns out I
had butt-dialed him during coffee and I
had spent the entire coffee talking
about how I wanted to get out and he
heard the whole thing heard the whole
thing and this was before they cut you
off after four minutes that was a good
28 minutes so he talking about how this
relationship was not working out for ya
yeah so is there some part of you that
thinks that that was meant to happen yes
that felt like divine intervention cuz
he said he said I heard what you said is
it true and I was like are we done yeah
yeah and and we were yeah so after what
you were like thanks but
the butt was like anytime I think you
didn't like George Clooney anyway
there's the surprise twist ending hey
thanks for watching please subscribe to
my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please